I wanna kick off a new segment with you, okay?
I'm gonna give you some examples of things
that might not be so great about,
let's say the quarantine and I'm gonna challenge you
to see the glass half full instead of half empty.
Lamorne, are you ready to see things On The Sunny Side?
(audience clapping)
Do I look ready?
(laughing)
You sure do.
Okay, let's play.
All right.
Hit me.
Now most of us are having to spend our days
in work meetings on Zoom, but on the sunny side...
On the sunny side at least we now know
that our boss has a dirty (beeping) bedroom.
(laughing and clapping)
Can use that for blackmail material
if you want to, you know?
(laughing)
That's not only optimistic, it's funny.
I love it!
Okay, perfect, point one Lamorne.
All right, social media is addicting
and you can be stuck scrolling for what feels like
forever and a day, but on the sunny side...
But on the sunny side I now know that
my ex-girlfriend is happily married
with someone better than me.
Oh.
So it's a real thing, it's a real thing.
By the way, I actually have a whole theory
about seeing your ex and their new life on Instagram.
Yeah.
What are the in between moments, Lamorne?
What's really happening in that relationship?
An image is just a moment.
100%.
I like to think that they don't talk at all
and that they have long car rides of silence
and that this is purely for Instagram (laughing).
Okay, it's St. Patrick's Day so the chances
of waking up with a hangover are very high,
but on the sunny side...
But on the sunny side, I guess I can do it
all over again with no consequence because hey,
it's a pandemic, you know what I'm saying?
Wine anybody, you know?
Totally.
And every day is Friday, and every day is Friday,
so it doesn't really matter.
I love alcohol is what I'm trying to say.
Okay, dating already has its challenges
and a pandemic makes it even more difficult,
but on the sunny side...
But on the sunny side at least you can
watch all the rom-coms you want, alone,
by yourself, in your bedroom.
Can we please open up bars again?
(laughing)
I feel like St. Patrick's Day
might be a giant kick off.
Yes.
Okay, we've been officially quarantining
for a year now, one year, but on the sunny side...
But on the sunny side, you have zero excuse
of why you have not downloaded my podcast yet,
Unwanted, it's out everywhere.
It's the greatest of all time.
I love it and definitely, definitely watch "Woke"
on Hulu while you're at it because it's extraordinary.
Yes.
(upbeat music)